the ultraconservative Florida Republican
had been warning all weekend that he was
going to call for the removal of the
speaker and at the first opportunity as
the house convened on Monday Matt Gates
pulled the trigger for what purose the
does the gentleman from Florida now seek
recognition Mr Speaker pursuant to
Clause 2 A1 of rule 9 I Rise to give
notice of my intent to raise a question
of the Privileges of the house the
gentleman will state the form of his
resolution declaring the office of
Speaker of the House of Representatives
to be vacant resolved that the office of
is hereby declared to be vacant that
objection the motion to reconsider is
laid on the table the final straw for
Gates appears to be the stop Gap funding
measure introduced by McCarthy and
passed with Democrats support the S
Gates and his fellow hardliners in the
caucus had blocked every attempt to pass
the government funding package Gates
also alleges that the house Speaker has
concluded a secret deal with president
President Biden to continue providing
assistance to Ukraine despite
Conservative Republican opposition
regardless of how you feel about Ukraine
money or border money these two things
should not be lumped together they
deserve their own dignity and their own
vote and the people are tired of seeing
the ways of Washington that jam
everything together in order to really
frustrate actual legisl Kevin mcarthy
has vly denied any secret Ukraine deal
and in recent days have been dismissive
of Matt Gates's resolve to remove him as
house Speaker he's more interested in
securing TV interviews than doing
something he wanted to push us into a
shutdown even threatening his own
district with all the military people
there who would not be paid the ultimate
irony with the slim Republican majority
in the house the only possible way that
Gates could get the simple majority
needed to remove the speaker is with the
support of Democrats and that's unlikely
to be forthcoming would you Mike Hanah
jaer
Washington make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer